alors la question du mali est
intéressante parce que il ya cet appel à
une puissance qui doit venir rétablir
l'ordre alors c'est un vieux système
vieille stratégie de propagande on dit
pas nous allons intervenir mais nous
sommes appelés et un gouvernement qui
joue un fantoche peut toujours rappeler
une puissance étrangère à venir
intervenir alors ça pose la question est
ce qu'on doit toujours répondre aussi si
demain les ukrainiens demande
d'intervenir contre la russie où les
estoniens est ce que nous allons
répondre à leur demande et d'autre part
il ya toujours cette question de
vocabulaire est ce que les français au
mali sont des occupants ou des
libérateurs
alors je répondrai par une petite
question plaisante qu'on me posait quand
j'étais enfant ma famille pour moitié
napolitaine à naples il y avait une
présence américaine militaire très
visible et on nous demandait quelle est
la différence entre un pays libre et un
pays occupé et la réponse c'est que le
pays libre il est occupé par les troupes
américaines
[Musique]
mais